if we can just finish up with you
reintroducing yourself again or you
state your name and if you'd like to say
a few quick words I'm Charles check
accountants I'm a mentee and have
English and premiu I love my country
I don't everything they asked me to do
as well
[Music]
many voting Episcopal six disappeared he
was all Cardinal tomato [ __ ] kintamani
multi vomiting Abby Dalton Sam Stein mum
- Mitch even their little bit of fear
the PRC Ayodhya's some state montanita
Minh such got no FEMA and we will burst
an English novel Jota son needs an
equivalent you kissed Amina that you
know Matisse toe in which you organic
Akio Mario Givens to emo
[Music]
judgment against a cartoonist is my
nickname Anna give me aya
chicks is my legacy Oh text mylegacy cut
a chick she's chicory one movie checker
Tomkins critique please his name was
Charles Marla Thompkins but we called
him checker and I am not sure why they
called him checker but everyone in my
family had some sort of a nickname
he got married I think about 1939 or
1940 and shortly after that he joined
the military
I think during the war every kid wanted
to join the army every kid you know you
get three squares a day you know there's
no word for nothing and but for such
young fellows just couldn't wait to get
in I think a lot of our brothers and
sisters who went overseas learned a
different lifestyle for the first time
people felt concrete under their feet
for the first time they saw buildings
fire intense stories high and read that
all personnel who could speak an Indian
language report to such-and-such a
hanger on such-and-such a day
checker reported he said there was about
600 Aboriginal people in there they were
broken up into small groups and into the
language groups and given him messages
to translate back and forth the Cree
came on top
[Music]
they had away of expression every
different type aircraft that they had
tsugumi's got back silly
that's a mosquito bomber tsugumi's is
mosquito and a bomber is an explosion in
Greek epic city they would attach the
American Air Force and they would talk
to one another and translate how many
aircraft is going in a certain time what
type aircraft bombers they had how many
would be going they say this is me on
the radio and the other pole earth the
other hand would be interpreting that
whatever message was sent
I don't think the Germans had a bloody
clue on what the hell was being sent
some foreign cold that no one heard of
happy Joe I'm going to eat the muffin
dough buck segi
but Easter only under sub-servicer but
we must stay he told us I give it a 7 to
800 Vatican City since Americans
couldn't understand what they were
saying they were just translated
messages fine I didn't said the hell
with it we'll use their own Indians
so then a guy is there enough it's
worldwide
[Music]
he didn't like the war because of this
destruction he saw and the action that
he was in
I told Checker it's about time our nice
tiles are getting some credit for what
they did and that's what he told me that
he was a code talker during the war I
asked him why he hadn't told me earlier
he said I was sworn to secrecy and
that's why he never said a word
holy smokes Frank
remember these that's the kind of
pictures they used to take when we doing
there and see old school it's great that
was in the wintertime the checkers right
there yeah he looked serious he was
never serious in the military look
serious
this must have been the very first day
in uniform they both look like hell you
know he couldn't have been add that
uniform the first thing he's trying to
look taller than me you know that's a
good picture he looks serious as hell
[Music]
really brings back lots of memories lots
of good memories it's really good
you
he didn't want to lead the parade he
just wanted the parade to be a parade
and he could have walked it from the
sides he was a great man
gave his heart
[Music]
although you can dissolve the three
Indians at first doesn't matter I dunno
I was asked
[Music]
if you listen to me I'm sorry and taking
up your time this is goodbye I guess
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
you
you
[Music]
you
[Music]
you